hey welcome back to the Wolfram
technology conference 2018 though I do
think we're Antarctica it got really
cold here I'm here just talking with
developers and other interesting people
using technology in really fun ways and
I'm here with John can you tell us a
little bit about what you do at Wolfram
and what is the Wolfram blockchain lives
yeah yeah so it's hard
you would hard to get the plural on
there because there's so many different
lab related companies but what we do is
basically we've taken a lot of the
research and development that might
relate to watching or distributed
technologies and we've moved that
license back to a subsidiary company and
that's what from watching labs so we
have a number of different projects that
were working on I think actually
Christian has discussed some previously
and I think Christian both Johan and
Christian are giving talks today but
what we do is work on one I would say
one very clear area we were working on
so we did a lot of like general research
and looking at different areas but is
developing integrations with different
public blockchains that are available so
pretty much the canonical blockchain
that people talk about a lot its Bitcoin
and we have an integration with Bitcoin
Christian has gone through previously
and that's going through today oh cool
cool yeah so hopefully the some of those
people will have maybe a little bit of
background then there's also aetherium
which is another sort of popular public
blotting and we have an integration to
aetherium as well and we are working on
a number of other blockchain
integrations with different public
blockchain companies and we're
partnering with them so that's one of
the things that I really work on and
I've been to a number of different like
other conferences outside of our
technology conference and then often at
our technology conference during the
past couple days I've run into
interesting folks who are interested in
pursuing projects professors as well
that's awesome
so these companies they have their
blockchain and they're interested in
integrating it yeah so I would say like
that's kind of the the first sort of
area and I should have answered that
more completely sorry but like the first
area is those blockchain integrations
and so yeah a lot of companies are
interested in integrating either their
public blockchain or if they have some
permission blockchain or side chain that
connects to a public blockchain for what
they would call like a decentralized app
basically an app that runs using the
blockchain as a store it's like kind of
like a database so it's partnering with
those folks and integrating there ways
that make use of Wolfram technologies so
that's this dispersant of area a second
area that's kind of like more of a
longer term project for us has to do
with what we would call a smart Oracle
and that's something that Steven
mentioned I think
on Tuesday and it's it's one of those
things that's a really poor name and
we're trying to get away from that
terminology but that's kind of like what
everybody recognizes it kind of an ass
and for smart contracts that are done on
the etherium sort of model they need a
way of communicating with data in the
world so one of the things that came
about is you have an Oracle that takes
information from the real world and
provides it to the watch it's poorly
named because on Oracle's like the
Oracle of Delphi where it was predicting
the future this is not predicting the
future it's just moving information more
like a bridge and where we sort of come
in at Wolfram is that hey we have this
amazing Wolfram knowledge base where we
spent you know over a decade and a half
yeah yeah so Wolfram Alpha came out in
2005 okay one like a best of show at
South by Southwest in 2010 like both
best of show so the the best overall
thing yeah
but then also the best technical
achievement so I've got two awards and I
think people from sorry good oh I'm just
missing so it's using that knowledge
base and powers yes exactly exactly so
that that same knowledge base but now
thinking about the requirements that
would be particular to empower the self
executing programs or smart contracts or
there's kind of an issue with jargon I
think in and block to me that we're
trying to escape that's one of the
reasons why I Steven tuesday-night sort
of said you know we try to use some of
the terms so people are familiar but
then we also try to be I think more
general in the terminology that we use
but yeah so as you said Jesse it's like
you know we started like 2004 with stuff
internally and like moved all the way up
to like so it's been like you know over
a decade and when you compare that to
that sort of knowledge that other people
would want to use I mean it's like
there's an we have this tremendous
resource really and we just see taking
that too
smart contract or self-executing
it's just a whole nother area that we
could really do well and I think we've
shown that we can do so well with alpha
when it comes to all these virtual
assistants that are out there as I'm
sure you know we're just we're used
everywhere so it's like it just seems
natural that we're gonna be used when it
comes to self executing programs or
smart contracts it's like a natural so
that's the other real area beyond the
integration and they kind of have a
contaminant relationship because black
teens also are there's all these
transactions that are taking place on
them so there's all that data and like
Steven likes to say like we want to make
all that data computable so you know
here's another great opportunity to do
that cool so so you think the reason
businesses reach out to Wolfram - yeah
yeah absolutely I think when you look at
our strengths I think one just as a
language there made lots of amazing
tools that we've integrated in a way
that other people just don't have so
developers might you know spend a lot of
time pulling and stitching together
libraries to make use of the the latest
sort of technologies and you can just be
tremendously productive and more from
language without having to do any of
that so I think that alone is huge but
then also when you look at computational
knowledge or head and shoulders above
everyone anyone else and I think that's
why you see like
us partnering with a lot of like fortune
500 companies fortune ten companies even
to provide that computational knowledge
so it's a tremendous strength so I think
from from that perspective what we're
doing with computational knowledge or
computable data making making these
different domains of data computable
it's what we've been doing for a very
long time so I think it's really natural
that people come to us mmm so Christian
mentioned yesterday that blockchain
isn't sort of like the nascent stages of
the technology sort of probably internet
was in the 90s do you see and maybe the
next ten years blockchain being sort of
a like with you know the help of Wolfram
technology sort of like automated and
efficient to the point where it's like
turning on a light switch or turning on
the button of your I think actually
that's a wonderful analogy because it's
like electricity we don't really think
about it I mean you don't think a lot of
it about a lot of enabling technologies
and I think that's something that Steven
mentioned maybe even last night as well
like when you're in the midst of one of
these disruptions when it comes to
technologies and how things are looked
at I think a lot of people in blockchain
like to think about it as going from an
era of centralized computing to
decentralized computing and that has
somewhat of it helps to sort of
democratize different technologies
because it means large companies won't
have
stores of your data you will be in more
control of your data and that's
certainly empower empowering for users
especially I think in the past maybe
three to five years we've kind of seen
different sort of movements toward
consumer privacy
in East in developed countries so I
think that that's that's something where
that's kind of like I'm nadiyah an
ideological driver then when it comes to
the technologies like Christian said I
think a lot of times technologies hit
the forefront and they're kind of hyped
in a lot of ways and people talk about
them and then kind of as they're used
more significantly they actually kind of
move to the background and that's
something I think we've seen with the
internet where in like like Christian
said in like 1999 or 2000 people are
like all the internet companies and
businesses and me this and then you know
but that was like a small subset of I
guess commercial activity yeah it was
called like e-commerce was like the I
think the term and people just concern
it like shopping yeah yeah exactly
exactly so it's one of those things
where people would say you know as you
said like ecommerce in someone would be
an e Taylor and that would be a huge
component maybe of their value
proposition that you can buy it online
and now we just think of like oh if you
go maybe to your favorite store that oh
I didn't buy it there but I'm gonna go
home and right yeah and I think it's a
natural sort of thing so I think over
time if
blockchains and ledger technologies
really advanced that the same sort of
thing will happen that it will go from
you know they're being blockchain
companies to lots of companies making
use of the technologies and hopefully
they'll be doing that there Wilfong yeah
it seems like a sort of natural well
thanks for chatting with me do you have
anything else you wanna like mention
about Wolfram blockchain labs or sort of
anything about blockchain technology um
no I think you covered it you had really
good questions and I think that I mean
that's the thing in general that we have
this really broad vision of the future
where self executing programs or smart
contracts are really pervasively used
and useful fontaine technologies and
that's where really because of our
computational data or computational
knowledge we'll really be effective in
making those smart contracts usable and
I think that's really a revolutionary
sort of shift from people kind of doing
things on paper with other people to you
programs doing it with programs or
machines doing it with machines and we
hope to enable those processes to take
place awesome cool well thanks again
John and stick around and I'll be
speaking with other really cool people